[Musica]
se ti dico di no e no asciughi sembra
mio nonno vado a scuola nessuno impara
tutto da un sogno tutto torni a casa più
bionda ha premiato la mer di scoperta
gli amici qualsiasi che ci guarda e ci
penso a te non guardare
voglio solo sangue il comando non lo
faccio non mi sono fatto perché
palloni ma fallisce campo e nasce dato
volte a comprarlo santino comando la
zona come il re leone mi lascerà tutto
invece che stanno a caronia sicuro
fantino c'era brutto nove anni è come
report rispetto a questo tetto detto no
[Musica]
no no no casi umani casi clinici a saga
bureau per la chimica educazione
siberiana mica educazione civica tester
notte come johnny molti infatti molti
nuovi tutti i personaggi a modo
rispettati come toni
manicardi clinici e pavia burro per la
chimica educazione siberiana mica
educazione civica esternate come già
molti vecchi volti nuovi e tutti i
personaggi modo rispettati come top 500
come top come volta gli altri studi ma
sì dopo morì dopo fiore porti fiori non
fu mai dal suo propone a mera frati
tutto nero come una pantera lei si
spoglia nuda quando viene sera guardo
sempre il culo sotto l'anno
me ne fotto di chi ha più seguaci non mi
piace non mi piace rai quale sia da
balenciaga
con i piedi vedo solo noi
maino classi con un frutti mani della
serie infinta rai della serie cazzo sei
nato giorno con i miei
poi da amici si venga figlia come tommy
serbi che chi poi dalla mia zenga che
chi poi da una leggenda quanti nomi
sull'agenda io nemici si li colleziono
portò a casa un agenda sto facendo disco
nuovo di casi umani casi clinici a saga
burro per la chimica educazione
siberiana mica educazione civica
letterman che come johnny lee molti in
vecchi volti nuovi e tutti i personaggi
e modo rispettati come toni casi umani
casi clinici e taglia burro per la
chimica educazione siberiana
meccanizzazione civica teste matte come
jamir molti vecchi volti nuovi
tutti i personaggi modo rispettati come
toni
[Musica]
voglio sentire qua mannaie
tutti sanno che ma lo fa cup ha già
avuti tutti tutti sanno che madonna
un team con tombe con te
tutti sanno che mangio passa passa tutti
tutti tutti sanno che ma gli basta un
punto
quando è con te
ma chi
nel giorno e mezzo quando la scuola
basta sono in cucina sembra un contorno
per la mia figlia portarlo in poeti
importa se non manca tutto
allora non mi parla genoma capita allora
non ti tocca anche lei lo sa che quando
sono basta spendere 10 mila euro per il
tonno mi stanno cercando bergo per mie
collo basta spendere 10 mila euro bel
ritorno mi stanno cercando per rompermi
il collo perché tutti sanno che il mago
un faccia a faccia a tutti e di tutti
sanno che mangia pasta contorno
[Musica]
marangio fatta
sempre italiano mangio solo basta
ma basta allora sarà beat allen hughes
herat
mangio solo applicare mangio solo sfida
in america mandavo non passa anche in
germania mangiare anche londra mangiamo
sono passato e allora diciamo basta
perché ho visto fare le rime ragazzi ben
ritrovati mi hanno copyright atto il
video di getting over it con all'altra
live quindi alla certo dai passi mavava
angola la mettiamo le canzoni
chissenefrega tanto e copyright atto a
prescindere allora signori signori ha
aggiunto la lavagna non l'ho presa per
le live come potrebbe sembrare che
magari le faccia tipo ciccio gamer che
scrivo i nomi di donatori non me ne
frega una sega di quello l'ho presa
perché devo registrare un video in
questi giorni domani nella che è il
video dei 5 milioni iscritti c'entra
questa lavagna quindi lo sto tenendo qua
e già che c'era scritto sta frase
signori siamo a di velo velo ve lo dico
adesso siamo a piazza siamo 4.977.000
più o meno 460 dite a tutti di
iscriversi per un motivo in particolare
perché saliamo a 5 milioni entro sabato
prossimo non questo figura di quello
prossimo e sarebbe figo far uscire lo
speciale 5 milioni sabato sarebbe carino
se non lo faccio uscire più avanti
process sabato il più figo quindi dite a
tutti i vostri amici alla nonna di
iscriversi a tutti ma corre monio se non
perdo che cuffie prima di salute perché
sarebbe carino fare uscite sono esce
quando li facciamo però sai se esce
proprio sabato con fighissimo non questo
sabato che dopodomani e ditelo colo colo
prossimo dai quindi evitato di
iscriversi laszlo iniziamo con ho visto
che abbiamo solo due ore e mezza per un
semplice motivo perché l'ultima volta
non avrei mai pensato di finirlo perché
e non impossibile di più vero
l'ultima volta se mi ricordate eravamo
rimasti che eravamo che si chiama le ore
in più o meno che sta sta praticamente
qui sotto sta qui sotto e adesso non ve
lo faccio vedere che se cado è un casino
che è più o meno a metà del gioco quindi
questo preciso momento siamo a metà john
getting over it è un gioco dove se cadi
cadi sei morto non sei morto ma devi non
c'è ai fini di gioca quindi che cosa ho
fatto
ci sono ripari per arrivare qua per
arrivare al punto di prima e ci metto
poco 5 10 minuti il per salire qua ci ho
messo un'ora questo pomeriggio
maledizione e ci sono saliti in modo
tale da che possiamo questo voglio fare
la parte successiva se non riesco a
farlo tutto pazienza se cado perché se
cado qua sotto e un casino se cado o un
altro account su steam o dovevo
ricomprato il 18 e sono di nuovo qui
quindi ho una vita in più se cado devo
svizzera country tra sull'altro account
e fare questa cagata qua mela hanno
prestato dal tracollo di grazie dio
grazie sarà grazie marco grazie under
the love carlo e sofia
gentilissimi dite a tutti gli iscriversi
dobbiamo arrivare a miliardi si no
vorrei veramente che uscisse salvato lo
speciale prossimo quindi tra enti dite a
tutti i rischi così anche il vostro
fratello
chiunque fa la differenza davvero
ragazza spacchiamo sennò pazienza chi se
ne frega però sarebbe veramente figo
dyck iniziamo se cado qui sto da qui
sotto proprio ancora più di questo punto
posso iniziare a questo punto qua una
volta sola
vuol dire che se cado poi anche la
seconda volta
niente più a ufficio di vivere direi che
possiamo cominciare let's golf
eravamo rimasti qua non mi ricorda
magari vi faccio vedere che cosa c'è
come si arriva in questo punto preciso
ma se da quello facevo della strada un
attimo se caricasse il video me lo farei
vedere non carica il video
perché in realtà ho semplicemente fatto
quella parte che non riuscivo a fare che
è questo un attimo che è questa questa
cioè io io ero arrivato qua nell'ultima
live qui qui poi questo è il lato è
facilissimo sto pezzo qua e io sono
semplicemente arrivato qui qui sopra qua
quindi ho fatto semplicemente quel
pezzettino piccolo piccolo capito basta
quindi non vi siete persi nulla rispetto
all'altra live grazie francesco che
visse guidato la marmotta
l'importante che la marmotta resti per
la marmotta iscrivetevi dobbiamo
arrivare a miliardi veramente ragazzi se
si iscrivessero tutti con l'altra
calmerà cosa voluta nuova quelli che
sono i live adesso saremo a metà strada
sarebbe fantastico
andiamo avanti e allora getting over it
mia copyright at all ultimo video quindi
fantastico quindi io sono partito con
con 500 toni perché tanto mi copyright
anno a prescindere mi vuoi fare un
incontri toscana io ti amo allora
volentieri
fammi finire che ti muovere e poi ci
pensiamo solo se finisco che di iorio
ciao gaia
io sto molto bene ti ringrazio spero tu
stia bene anche tu allora per chi non ha
seguito l'altra live vi prego fate vela
perché è impossibile toniolo io non ho
mangiato una sega perché ho dovuto fare
la parte in prima di rieti gove rigidi
non son riuscito a mangiare niente
e quindi mangerò appena finito la diver
se dio vuole
e niente mangiamo pasta con tonno non in
live silver
ciao gaia sto molto bene grazie solo un
pochettino raffreddato ma io vivo la mia
vita nel raffreddore ogni tanto sono non
influenzato ma è raro rogo è raro io non
ho ancora capito come si fa a non essere
o non cristo nar e quando si gioca sta
roba perché se non salgo qui in altre
due martellate di gesù porco demonio
come si sale di sopra scusatemi grazie
firefly gentilissima le slot
ripeto la lavagna non è per i donatori
non me ne frega nulla di fare la roba lì
anche perché lavaggio ciccio game è
perché betis tv e io devo arrivare allo
stop di mortacci mia quel cappello lì si
compra da qualche parte noi che ci siamo
come si fa come fanno gli speed runner a
farlo subito visto che io sto
riscontrando problemi a farlo
normalmente non si fa eva britt e
moriamo la pasta al tonno finita male e
allora non riecco pur code ma allora
come avevo fatto io nei miei video
scusatemi per questa parte è veramente
impossibile non riesce a darti la spinta
necessaria a meno che non debba fare
così forte
no grazie la vidi utilissimo sii forte e
una sega perché deve essere lui forte
non io devo devo come ci si arriva lì su
scusatemi se date datemi il discusso dai
come come come dovrebbe come dovrebbe
arrivarci spiega michele altissimo fase
dove spaccarmi di sotto così non ce la
faccio ce la faccio video caricare gli
devo scaricare ce la faccio giuro giuro
ma se mi impegno c'è la semi dopo
grazie sheila
datemi la forza vipre datemi un martello
nuovo
pensate se dovessi fare questa parte che
ogni volta che caso dovrei iniziare dall
inizio
no perché va bene
dio mio cosa che problemi hai io ho
seriamente
io non ho tanto paura di non riuscire ad
andare avanti ho più paura di riuscire a
ritornare di tutto indietro perché se
torno tutti dietro da smerciare account
e se lo switch poe se ritorno dietro una
seconda volta cielo nel culetto ci sono
saluto tutti i tutti i presenti si
scrivono con un secondo a cantone della
ragazza e con un terzo e con un quarto e
con quello che volete mio dio non esiste
mondo in cui io possa vivere non è ma
devo fare un respiro perché non sto
capendo grazie criba devo morire
grazie a iano grazie sheila elsa
williams 6 una tennista calmiamoci 3 2 1
ma perché non sono in grado di fare una
cosa easy io lo ammazzo ve lo giuro
avermelo ve lo svelo disintegro la cosa
bella che seccando qui sotto per come
risalgo perché sei stupido perché perché
eravamo arrivati devi tornare giù perché
cioè
meno male che attira tempo di sull'altra
tastiera perché se la tirava su questa
la mia tastiera non la fanno più ed è
una tastiera silenziosa della reyer
sembra che sia fascino un placement data
non me ne frega na sega quindi se la
rombo non la posso più comprato che non
la fanno più anche mia zia
anche mia nonna e mia ti seguono le poi
salutare grazie tamara e lucia che sono
la zia di sarah e fate iscrive anche la
nonna la nonna c'è anche già iscritte a
posto ma dorate non ti chiedo di niente
voi tutti che non avete scritto la nonna
fate un account alan horn e scrivete
perché la mia vita fa schifo perché devo
giocare a questa merda per il resto
della mia vita e morire come si fa
come ci sono anche grazie giulia grazie
di esserci
secondo me importante come si chiama il
tipo questo pelato non lo so rega che
non è propriamente pelato e semi pelato
semi mastrolindo non lo so ragazzi come
si chiama interessa veramente pentola il
pentolaio io vi ammazzo tutti tutti
quelli che mi hanno consigliato questo
gioco liano marzo non so come si fa a
vivere perché poi tratto non è che ho
fatto delle prove prima perché ho detto
mica magari cadeau quindi non provo
niente
dio mio da allora sei stupido nella vita
morte e miracoli
grazie gaia il ritorno ai prestatori noe
per natale si può joshua ciao marco e
sofia buon salve a tutti quelli che sono
arrivati a leh non devo toccare la
roccia forte la fra della mela infilerei
lo sapete dove voi a lui gliela può
significare perché c'è la pentola che lo
copre però se nella vita io avessi del
culo perché sono stupido allora faccio
un altro tentativo poi guardo nella
speed run come lo fanno perché secondo
me non esiste che nella vita io non
riesca a fare
fatevi vedere come la fanno nella sfida
di giro voglio morire voglio morire
adesso voglio morire in questo mondo
fammi vedere come la fanno nella sfida
non vi prego iddio si è ovvio se va beh
li ho visti io mi spingo da qua da qui
lui si spinge da qua cosa come questo è
scemo
voi siete la rovina della mia vita io ve
lo dico come fai a spingerti da qui che
non sai neanche salire su quella di
sopra ma come fai a spingersi da qui è
impossibile ma non non è possibile mai
come fa a spingersi da lì io a stento ci
arrivo dal da di sopra come ha fatto
ragazzi qualcuno a una mia una delle
peugeot è stata sera qui e là nomi come
si chiama che se la roma ho bisogno del
ricambiano la vendono più quindi per
cortesia qualcuno mi min e ho bisogno di
una tastiera e di un salvataggio di se
qualcuno ha un account di steam questo
gioco me lo presti perché che più avanti
di me ovviamente perché secondo me non
la pasta bar e invece no perché ciò
proprio invece il mondo mi vuole male
perché proco demonio non esiste che lui
si tiri da qua come fa io non arriva
neanche nella roccia sopra subito sopra
figurati in quella la sua ma perché sono
stupido puoi portare per un grande hotel
umbra il necrologio in seguito di black
bloc ma è una moda di amnesia è figo
grazie al consiglio volentieri vediamolo
via michetti catanzaro taglia che ce la
fai si parla se ce la faccio nudo mi
metto nudo
allora se però la mia vita fa schifo me
lo deve dire subito che tipo di giochi
di macchine quando quando curvi dtt
storici uguale uguale quando tiro mi
chino su pace così come se potesse
andare più sul personaggio perché il
mondo è brutto
[Musica]
l'ho fatta dove c'è il cappello di
satana dai c'era il cappello ma perché
perché quel cappello esiste non è vero
ti prenderai jean force jump force l'ho
visto ed è molto figo probabilmente sì
in questo gioco mi servirebbe jean force
non so se le avete colto da che ho
bisogno di di un devi essere incazzato
per riuscirci allora avrei già finito il
gioco tra al sicuro perché il mondo non
è vero e piatto perché mica visto
veramente il bene perché poi metto il
mouse proprio dritto cristo aspetta
sopra sopra stai zitto esterno e muori
ok perché salti comunque ragazzino non
voglio più esistere in possiamo c64 asta
parte mai incontrato e che poi se cadi
non non ti devi fare tutto da zero sono
vista ray ucciso no vabbè vabbè ma che
iscrivetevi con tutti gli account
avete se ne avete di più su iscrivetevi
braico di arrivare a 5 milioni
in questa settimana per far uscire video
dei 5 milioni sabato prossimo se esiste
il mondo però dovete dirmi se arriviamo
ai cicli ogni sabato il video che sto
per girare di 5 milioni che visto
spaccando per girarlo non avete sarà il
video di youtube meglio del rewind nokia
rewind sia chissà che cosa
perché io faccio schifo tra l'altro
rispondo a esatto esatto il commento che
sta arrivando adesso tra l'altro l'ho
detto prima
preferisci questo è primis be happy uil
se ti ho detto tu puoi notare ragazzi vi
prego non fatemi non a sony per salutare
perché brutto ciao tony ti saluto grazie
alla donazione però non mi piace
salutare la gente perdona se qui non mi
chiedete cosa penso che questo è
l'ultimo ok perché non un saluto per
donazioni è un gesto brutto sogno
questa è la domanda elia bella loreti
seguo dai 500.000 suo si faceva parte
poi ti rispondo perché secondo me io
spacco qualcosa ve lo giuro su dio ma
l'avevo fatta in modo easy simo tempo fa
ce l'ho fatta sarà forte non inglobati
cappello via il cappello tua sorella
morta ok
bene adesso ti rispondo ci ho messo
venti minuti a fare questa parte bene
questo merita liti iscrivetevi al canale
tutti anche chiunque chi un cugino
mandate il messaggio e fate account
bella loreti se vuole 500 iscritti
grazie e non sono ancora riuscito a
tratti dal vivo meno male se non ti sei
iscritto
ma ci riusciva bene grazie cosa ne pensi
delle hit su youtube rewind viene 18
ecco volevo risponderti perché o li
spenda che a youtube fa cagare che ha
fatto fino a oggi che quindi mi basta un
po di iscritti si spera che ricambierò
un giorno
qua mi devo agganciare al gancio la e
spetta non mi devo agganciare al gancio
sono stupido dovevo andare più
direttamente sopra va bene tutto se cado
qui va bene chissenefrega c muoio dentro
sto buco
basta che non cado di nuovo sotto la
sinistra perché non ci sono più risalire
quassù dicevo allora cosa ne penso del
rating di youtube rewind
vi do due risposte alla la prima mia
nonna saltava di più per hobby grazie
tente motogp fa cagare che secondo me sa
che hai dato un sacco nel titolo ma chi
d'altronde chi non lo fa quindi chi se
ne frega basta che voi capiate bene che
non sono ipocrita non so quanto questa
espressione mi renda giustizia però
fatemi fare il salto scusate perfetto
perché il video del rewind
io l'ho fatto innanzitutto in un odio
fort nike primo io odio la community di
four nights e neanche tutta ma odio
quelli che mi dicono come giocare a
forza infatti il mio video perché odio
fornet odio e tra virgolette perché se
avessi scritto perché odio la community
livorno e sarebbe stato meno click day
quindi è il discorso è più
[Musica]
quindi io non odio format prima e
seconda cosa il rewind il se riesco
accendo un cero
il mio ruolo di four nights nel rewind
non l'ho scelto io me la io sono andato
a londra per fare riguarda che mi ha
detto vuoi partecipare rewind cazzo si e
quando e quando ho partecipato a rewind
mi hanno detto lee in loco cosa dovevo
fare
ho detto ruolo fa vj ford ma non credo
unico gioco che non faccio perché hanno
chiamato maker un game lande tra
fornelli
no però vabbè che dicevo no no non lo
faccio non lo fa attorno al in italia va
be lo facciamo porta il primo perché non
odio farne due perché si trattava di un
secondo
e vabbè altra cosa io non sapevo com'era
rewind perché rewind di quest'anno e
adesso ci arrivo e molto critici
compresa la mia scena dall'altro ma va
benissimo ed è il v sì il video youtube
rewind questo è il video più this
laicato di tutta youtube in una
settimana record del mondo
cit del video con più dislike nella su
questo il video da youtube rewind dove
ci sono io il video più dislocato di
tutto internet in una settimana ha
superato justin bieber baby e del video
compiti is like prima cosa che voglio
dire non me ne frega una sega perché
molti mi dicono mi dispiace dirtelo ma
se non so come come la vedi come se mi
potesse fare qualcosa che fosse video
proprio dislike mi dispiace un po perché
se fosse senza di sly che sarebbe figo
dai bella è andato bene però allo stesso
tempo e figo che io sia nel video cui
più dislike senza averne diretta colpa
dalla fine mica l'ho fatto io il video
ci sono in una frazione di secondo e
tutto il video ad avere problemi
nella mia parte la mia parte fa solo
parte dei tanti crimini ce ne sono di
molto peggiori quindi è figo poter dire
io ho fatto il video con più dislike di
youtube ma la gente non è che se la
prende con me e questa cosa è strana se
non riesco più a fare sta parte mi
ammazzo e si getting over it è difficile
da fare e in più devo rispondere i
commenti
quindi è figo che ci che io sia il
ridolfi di sla è una cimento va bene chi
se ne frega e io sto facendo dei salti
veramente mi vorrei uccidere ripeto per
un mese volta finché siamo in tanti
iscrivetevi tutti al canale sono stati
iscritti perché serviamoci camion
iscritti prima di sabato il video
sabato prossimo il video esce degli
speciali 5 milioni essa il cuscino a
sabato 22 sarà il video più bello della
vita
ci abbiamo messo due settimane per
registrarlo non abbiamo ancora finito
non avete non potete immaginare niente
prove è bello complimenti fa vj sei
proprio un videogiocatore da anni si
vede che lo fai
quindi chi se ne frega dei disagi mi
dispiace comunque io a prescindere non
sapevo che cosa sarei andato a fare
quando mi hanno invitato e ne sapevo
com'era rewind ci ho partecipato per
detto vediamo come venuto story wine
vediamo in che punto mi hanno messo mi
hanno messo verso la fine non sapevo
niente ma col senno di poi l'avrei fatto
comunque perché cavola comunque un
rewind quindi tanta roba poi sono finito
due volte in un video di più di pai
signori due volte quello di di di oggi
ci sono adesso commento il meme è perché
mi ha fatto ha messo in un membro view e
nel video dell'altra volta e ci ho fatto
un'area che ovviamente riguardo che
uscirà mi pare lunedì impegniamoci
nefasta parte
non è vero non è sì è vero perfetto mi
fate mi arriva la super non è vero
ragazzi non cioè fino a una certa stacco
perché non mi voglio uccidere ti voglio
uccidere
io non ho come minchia si fa questa
parte scusatemi niente dunque non ho
visto il video di ripagare hanno fatto
in tempo a livello perché oggi ho fatto
mille cose scusatemi quindi non so
neanche che non ti ha detto nel video
però ho letto il titolo risposta web e
ai commenti e comunque va beh tutti
erano del tipo è ma fa non hai capito
che fa vige non odia four nights ma odia
la community
va beh chi se ne frega basta gaia voci
non iscritti e vabbè comunque video
rewind quindi a cosa ne penso delle
thing arrivando ancora non l'ho spiegato
praticamente il rewind avuto eating per
tanti motivi perché kringe perché non
hanno proprio capito bene youtube che
cosa vuole la gente perché questo rewind
è stato fatto della serie diamo alla
gente quello che la gente vuole tipo
finire questo gioco è però loro non
sanno proprio bene che cosa che cosa che
cosa vuole la gente quindi hanno messo
che hip hop che c'è una parte di
pubblico che lo adora ed è molto però è
utilizzato quindi molti lo hanno odiato
non hanno messo più di pai e questa cosa
qua andata in testa a tutti quanti
perché pd by versus the series sta
facendo tante cose e hanno porco demonio
morto ieri messo tanti youtubers
sconosciuti a livello globale tipo me
tipo tanti altri tanto piccola parentesi
nella scena di forma il tuo fausto c'era
gente che che generavano 66 77 forse io
non faccio forte eppure tra tutti quelli
ero quello che ci stava ci azzeccava di
più perché gli altri non erano neanche
gamer quindi va beh chiusa parentesi
per farvi capire cosa centro e comfort
niente ma gli atri c'entrano ancora di
meno
p per il culo
e questa roba qua no cosa che mi è
accaduto
no non è vero non è vero non è vero non
è vero
no lega no vi prego non ci credo che non
è successo
no raga non è vero sto guardando il
replay
questa è la scena più bella del mio
canale di sempre e più bella del
serpente vado
no dai veramente con un jobs kerr no
mica non me l'aspettavo ma malanno non
c'era suo pacco prima l'hanno aggiornato
io non avevo mai visto sto bacco pensavo
fosse un oggetto tipo il cappello c'era
un jump scherno l'anno aggiunto non
c'era prima
ma dai mi sono pure cannavà [ __ ] non
ci credo e non è nuovo non non c'era
prima jump square non ci sono caduto
perfettamente nella trappola che
volevano fare nostra parte me la rivedrò
il loop per tutta la vita
no vi prego klippa tela qualcuno laulala
carichi sul suo canale dtt ad iscriversi
non ci credo perfetto perfetto perfetto
no non so come perché mi stavo
concentrando forse o forse perché l'ho
fatto 6 mila volte cioè io sono riuscito
a cadere non ci credo vi giuro
fatevi un attimo in fare la devo salvare
e vede la scena più bella dei miei video
tipo da sempre
no non ho visto lasciato sarete morti da
ridere
no vi giuro mi sono caricato mar vabbè
che non c'era prima
io quanti ne ho fatto sto gioco guardate
il mio gameplay vecchio non c'era l'anno
aggiunto il
il gems che non c'era prima non c'era
prima società musker porca vacca che
kakà e per halloween ancora era per
halloween quel un easter egg di
halloween
beh ottimo visto che siamo a natale
cribbio
vabbè mi sono perso col discorso non mi
ricordo che cosa stavo dicendo voglio
morire adesso voglio morire in questo
nome anche perché io devo arrivare sì sì
stai fermo fermo che è perfetto per
calmati chi prego iddio ora non mi
ricordo come si va di là se devo tirarmi
d'acqua o devo tirarmi da questa roccia
alla mia scelta è fondamentale perché se
sbaglio roccia cadeau fatemi vedere la 2
milioni ciare per corti no perché quelli
sì nello speed run si no non si sa dove
bilancio da qua se cado ragazzi ho
sbagliato a fare sto video
iscrivetevi tutti perché dovrebbero
arrivare i cinque ma si vede la scritta
dal per come sono organizzate
iscrivetevi al canale che dobbiamo
arrivare ai 5 milioni prima di sabato
prossimo
metti la nello speciale cinque anni no
perché lo speciale 5 milioni e diverso
da quello che ho pensato non è non è un
classico speciale è molto molto meglio
il più bel non potrò mai fare più
vigorosi perché troppo fatto bene ci ho
messo troppo tempo un mese quindi non
avete idea farà riderissimo vi lasciate
perdere
fatevi concentra questa non è la più
bella lei che ho fatto da quando faccio
live tra parentesi a scusami giovanni
nuti risposto cerca su you tube niente
non eletto
allora vi leggo yacoub scusatemi non ho
letto i commenti mara grazie mille ciao
l'oro sia account di google mi sono
iscritta con tutti e sei grazie mille
ragazze avete più account iscrivetevi
perché finalmente l'esca vedere una lei
per colpa del lavoro aveva tanto
rimangono salvate grazie mara
gentilissima davvero mi fai un regalo
incredibile la donazione grazie mille
comunque ma perché ti sei iscritta con
tutti account fatelo tutti se avete più
account youtube perché mi serve
tantissimo per arrivare entro sabato
prossimo i 5 milioni grazie giovanni
cerca su youtube e rue cyrus roussef
russian push up meme vuoi vedere se ci
riesci perché
vabbè poi vediamo grazie e grazie
rebecca sarà rybin ore becco letto non
ti chiamavi rebecchi mari sarà visto
consolando con la live domani o la
verifica in inglese
allora parlerò in inglese per tempo non
è vero guardati di pai che sono io che
parlo in inglese
vado non ci credo non ci voglio credere
devo arrivare dall'altra parte dove
minchia el'altro ok
eccolo no si perfetto se cadono rifarmi
tutto non è vero
raga devo concentrarmi tantissimo no no
no no no no no no no no sì no rega
non sono incazzato perché ho sbagliato
non solo non sono incazzato per un
motivo perché ho sbagliato io ho fatto
un movimento che non dovevo fare
marco demonio porc sono stupido mi casse
cadevo più di sotto e roero finito
eravamo alla eravamo all 80 per cento
del gioco fatto quello finito cioè non è
vero però quasi non sono incazzato per
un motivo perché ho sbagliato io ho
fatto un movimento che non dovevo fare
eravamo all'ottanta per cento rega era
avevo fatto tantissimo
stop minchia di cappello fammelo
togliere dalle imprese di casco di no
scherzavo andiamo avanti per cortesia
perfetto ma perché potrei incazzare
misure se cadevo da li avresti voluto
essere blur in quel mons
sì assolutamente
se cadevo tissot non sono incazzato per
due motivi uno perché ho sbagliato io e
so di aver sbagliato in società con il
gas di più quando so che non solo quando
so che il gioco che mi vuole male con
quando sbaglio io lo sbaglio io colpa
mia lo scemo miti rondo schiaffi a fine
live non li meli fico per gli states
militi da solo marco meloni no grazie
sarà del soddisfando e due perché poteva
andare molto peggio poteva cadere ancora
più sotto e lì mi sarei dovuto giocare
il secondo salvataggio che è l'ultimo
che ho non ci credono
ah ecco mi sembrava lui adesso ci riesco
sempre grazie krizia grazie sarà adesso
ti leggo fammi fare sta parte non ci
metto sei anni in concentrare sia però
regala un attimo vi prego la teca che ha
addosso voi e con steve jobs che grazie
mille marghe un attimo
sì ecco come ho fatto prima vetta ci sei
anni adesso ci scusi il suo gioco e così
quando non riesci a fare una parte poi
riesci sempre c'è più o meno non ho
letto cosa mi aspetta un attimo che sarà
mi ha fatto meglio da ridere meno male
che ti sei divertito se anche
preoccupata perché questo grossi chiama
geraldo giuseppe non ho capito cosa
intendi per ok nel prossimo video rewind
ti metteranno una pentola con un piccone
ma centrati di fort knight e sicuramente
lo avrei fatto molto più volentieri tra
l'altro infatti forza puoi farcela più o
meno però grazie saverio valerio che
sono scarso ma regala ste parti sono
veramente difficile e dura sopravvivere
incastrati dentro un vaso è sì
iscrivetevi con tutti gli account che
avete il mio canale grazie prego ciao
non è vero non esistono nel mondo ma
neanche salire lì sopra che è veramente
da deficienti dai madonna lega veramente
faccio bo mitare vomitare
secondo me io sbaglio la direzione del
dai dai dai dai dai perché è difficile
salire lo scopro perché l'hanno fatto
difficile sto gioco perché dovevo fare
proprio questa roba su youtube non
potevo fare
make up
ragazzi io non ti giuro su dio se non
smetto ho fame tra tra l'altro e quando
sono quando ho fame quando sono affamato
m'incazzo ancora più facile noi
ok stai fermo grazie prego bene molto
bene
mi state scrivendo tutti con gli account
grazie mille ragazzi veramente voi non
avete idea di quanto questa cosa mi
faccia piacere perché vorrei proprio
uscire prima di natale con il video di
specie il convoglio speciale col video
di speciale 5 milioni di iscritti
manco l'italiano fatemi concentrare
scusate vista parte delicata e delicata
finchè questo ho sbagliato nell'ultimo
che vorrei evitare di fare lo stesso
errore
no è troppo non è vero
noi abbiamo 52 ore meno e io se non
finisco questo gioco mi ammazzo
il firmware cela una lavagna così per
scrivere cagate quando facevi lo che
dite voi che dite vi piace come idea la
passione la prendo una lavagna ad
attaccare dietro ma non per le live
proprio per lì per i video tipo voglio
morire adesso non so no non ci credo lo
sta rifacendo ancora nonostante scrivi
un casino lo sto facendo per lì bene
degli iscritti
perché se arriviamo a 5 milioni dove
cioè 5 milioni adesso la prossima
settimana
sarebbe fantastico perché vorrei far
uscire il video dei 5 milioni in tempo
non ho sbagliato scusa fatto switch sua
webcam perché io se riuscisse ad
arrivare ai 5 milioni entro sabato
prossimo faccio mi uccido e video come
blog dei sabato prossimo ed è un video
da paura
e perché non faremo più il nostro pin e
l'api non faremo più stanchi l'italiano
parte 2 non sto più nella pelle e voglio
farvi vedere quanto è bello quel video
quindi solo per quel motivo li capito
uscirebbe comunque però sabato sarebbe
proprio quello prossimo con questo farlo
questo degrado dei fatti pop intimi
descritti in un giorno è impossibile
manco pd poi perché non esiste e moto di
salire qui sopra di nuovo quella parte
veramente un casino però ho capito lo
sbagliato primo capitolo sbagliato
adesso quindi in teoria poi un serpente
lo non è non è vero ce l'ho fatta
no molto bene piano seri se arrivo di
sopra è fatta c'è più o meno dai dai dai
che vivevano pannelli ti piace l'idea
della lavagna ti potevo contare per i
sulla faccia perché questa videocamera
l'olmo investito dei soldi perché sono
tirchi o solo a volte solo a volte
voglio morire dai ok non è vero però
sono tornato qua proprio tra l'incudine
e il martello
forse non li merito questi 5 milioni
però vabbè io vi dico solo che dopo il
video speciale dei cicli di potrei anche
smettere di fare video non è vero sto
scherzando
però per quanto è bello e non ce la
faccio più a tenerlo segreto voglio
farmi vedere
quanta forza a quest'uomo nelle braccia
tanta quanta forza o io nel fare questo
video in realtà di più non ha tanta
stavo scherzando
tanti auguri per i cinque piani in
anticipo grazie a andrew and last
guardian
grazie speriamo le varie 5 milioni non
si fanno in anticipo porta sfiga dai
perché non ci arriva uno spoiler previto
speciale ragazzino non ve lo è un video
talmente diverso da tutti i miei vi far
liberissimo che non posso non so come
non so neanche come spoiler al vero è
veramente incredibile sport
cosa vuoi fare chiavo intanto per i 5000
ti facevo invece viene anticipo poi
salutarmi unica si chiama tortina orca
vacca gusti saluti
ti saluto tortina però vi prego non mi
chiesero tali donazioni e brutto è
brutto come gesto suo nome quindi ti
saluto perché 6 gentile ma
basta ok basta per salutare la gente
perché vi prego è brutta come cosa ok
tanto da sembrare niente mi frega molto
di iscritti che ci arriviamo ai 5
milioni perché voglio avere questa b per
il culo non so neanche come pronunciare
qui i nomi però chi no grazie però no
ragazzi
ecco fate iscrivere tutte le persone con
sei iscritto a il mio canale te prego
almeno per fare uscire v day 5 milioni
propone anche levarla vi sembra ok qua
prima ho sbagliato se riesco a capire
come ho sbagliato non sbaglio di nuovo
perfetto lo è andata a volte è meglio
non pensarci alle cose mi piace un ansia
addosso una rete idea non ridete vi
ammazzo mi sono appena scritta con
l'account di me ma da brava create
account fatelo anche ai cugini vado noi
ok questa è l'ultima
non era l'ultima scherzavo questa è
l'ultima dove sono caduto prima qua come
ho fatto a cadere qua se lo fa da sola
forte ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta ce
l'ho fatta ci ha fatto ho fatto bene
calmi calmi calmi calmi calmi ok siamo
quasi arrivati a quasi arrivati a questo
schifoso lurido rettile se lo cavalco
stacco la live perché mi torna
all'inizio
anzi vi faccio perché magari motivo e
non lo fa non mi faccio solo vedere un
secondo che cosa fa questo serpente solo
questo play snake
qualcuno l'ha campionato tranquillo ci
vado io a pile con la faccio vedere
monti secondo cosa falsamente perché
magari in cui alcuni voi non lo sapevo
un bar è quello di programmava se avete
fatto non dite niente di niente sono già
incassato non va bene ma non importa non
lo farò
non vedo stupido da una labile scivola
di capelli non sono cambiati molto bene
e non sapevo sul naso in stupida non si
vede perché ciò per campionato alla fine
cioccio più proporzionale
ma scusate ma questa è quella è la
faccia
quella è la faccia che non avete visto
forse in pieno ma meno male di una
persona che vuole morire del e di una
donna per cui uccidere ciccio gamer
molto bene per i video consigliabile
andiamo avanti
io ho fatto vedere cosa è successo
quello che questo è quello che succede
se prendi quindi sembra non lo prendiamo
e meglio se lo prendiamo per sbaglio
muoio anzi prima pin prima che ciò
l'altro account con cui devo rifarmi
comunque tutto sto pezzo qua anche con
quello dopo cado ho finito alive
speciali cicognani attesissimo regalo so
e non posso dirvi niente mi dovete
scusare veramente mi saluti sono stefano
grazie mille di avermi sono stefano pro
ti chiami lucrezia con l'account che
facciamo un dis in volentieri kiwi così
prendo siti iscritti
allora gli scrive the go tutti a kant
che avete lesbo mi chiamo ottima questa
cosa che ho fatto subito se non cado giù
ma no no no no no no ragazzi
no ragazzi
no
mi ha fatto ridere pre safe to vai
rispetti
quanto vorrei essere ben due
io non
ma poi ma prima poi per perché no
ragazzi cioè dai ma perché
ma poi ne ha ma poi nemo hanno quindi
anche col serpente capito ci sono caduto
dalla porta sotto come come minchia ho
fatto a cadere sotto il serpente sotto
sotto
no ragazzi c'erano vabbè dai carichiamo
l'altro a causa mi va bene che un altro
account perché sono interromperla live
ma ma please
no no sotto il set
sotto il serpente c'è neanche 10 do
preso servette sono un troglodita sotto
come dai ma fate i seri
no ragazzi cioè non mi sento proprio in
grado di ricoh vabbè familiare sull'alto
account aspetto solo gando su steam con
l'altro account che non è mio
non posso far vedere ovviamente se non
si vede la paz
no ragazzi cioè non è possibile ma poi
mamma poi ma dai ma passò sotto sotto il
serpente sono caduto sotto il serpente
non sopra neanche 10 min qia no no no no
ragazzi io vi giuro su dio non ma ne ma
neanche un rincoglionito ma come ho
fatto a cadere sembra propone sembra che
l'ho fatto apposta
ci hai capito se io sembra che l'ho
fatto apposta sta roba
un coniglio non posso dirlo che non è
femminili un deficiente ma di quel limbo
proprio non ho parole io non so non so
proprio cosa dire
ragazzi non so come ho fatto
ma poi come si logga qua credibile no
non me le merito non me le medium via
via non mi merito niente grazie però
grande al freddo davvero un bel fungo
cosa c'è io sono sono da uccidere vi
giuro su dio
ma poi no ma ragazzi ma di cosa stiamo
parlando ma poi sono caduto
io sono
sto rientrando sul getting però devo
ripartire dal da va beh sono orribili
come persona e io mi sento in dovere di
dirvi che che voglio morire
no ragazzi io non ho solo più questa
vita non ho più perché ma sono sono
stato previdente nel farmi fare un altro
account
cioè nel farmi prestare una tra canada
mio amico che è che più bravo di me che
è arrivato fino qua mi ha detto senti
arrivati fino a lì che se il cadeau ed è
successo intorno almeno qui perché sennò
non ha senso
no ragazzi io non non so cosa dirvi te
lo giuro mi sono impegnato tantissimo
vabbè grazie dai tori non è successo
niente dai torniamo come prima come
prima sono forte speedrun speedrun
motore non è successo perché no perché
sono vado in down tutto il video bike si
deve aiutarmi gioco ti prego ti
scongiuro nonna ecco un cazzo allora
secondo di nuovo non ho più vite non
posso più fare niente perché questo è un
altro account
quindi se cado io giudico del punto di
prima io non ho più account
quindi io vado a [ __ ] ho finito il
video o fatti scrive tutti i miei piedi
mare parenti non ho più nessuno bene fa
ricreare un altro account e ricomincia
ragazzi sto male iscrivetevi al canale
di breve almeno rel
almeno iscrivetevi al canale dove la
saba q node che si era salvato mondo di
getting over it ces a baku al posto di
doba beh la rigiocata subito sarebbe
fighissimo fa vj non maico veterana come
si fa la sabaco modena ho subito l'avrei
fatta
ma ci sono il modo di studio ma
scusatemi ci sono i mod
sarebbe finissimo che fortuna che ti
apprezzato la cantano che fortuna
gliel'ho chiesto io che un account con
cui condivido tutti i giochi ma e
l'account non è mio amico che è molto
più bravo di meglio però se lui fa la
speed run proprio sfida 9 di cinque
minuti
sempre meglio di che cinque ore togliti
grazie
e se cado qua i ragazzi abbiamo finito
mica che è successo baseball come caduto
li fa me lo aveva lasciato lì se finisco
se cado stavolta ciao
no no io non so come ho fatto a cadere
un troglodita e roero
ma non male ma va pero lasciamo perle
dai noi sta e successo di tutti instaura
di live che milioni di jump square
quello tutto
no ragazzi vi giuro salaj della live
della juve la riguardano tutta la vita
style è bellissima per voi per me è una
merda ma per me è fantastico quindi qui
nel momento in cui sono caldo mi verrà
da ridere riguardandola ma se cade
un'altra volta l'abbiamo finito è finito
il gioco ve lo dico quindi io ho ora
faccio non c'è un modo per evitare di
prendere serpente quel punto vivo il
punto è quello che mi dà fa perché quel
punto a quel punto posso tornare
indietro se la passo è fatta ma seguo
cugat
devo essere bravo a non cadere giù col
serpente però impossibile perché poi non
è che cadi qua qua cadi tutto indie devi
rifare un po non posso vincere quindi in
questa live o lo finisco perché se passo
con la parte lo finisco sicuro o non lo
finisco e la la prova finale polo
finisco o no c'è solo questo da fare è
la prova della della vita sei depresso è
un po sì cosa ti da youtube quando
arrivi a 5 milioni come premio un calcio
nel culo se ti interessa se non ci sono
premi per i 5 milioni
ci sono per i dieci per l'ultimo premio
di youtube di da solo dai 10 milioni che
però dice non penso non lo so se in
italia ci si può arrivare perché siamo
troppo pochi ma van culo se va bene va
bene va bene ma io io invece l'ho mica
iscrivetevi con tutti i canali che avete
vi prego so che tu che stai cola non
l'hai fatto perché non hai fatto fallo
dobbiamo arrivare ai 5 milioni in tempo
porco demonio porco no
intanto sto verso che ho fatto lo fa
anche lui ama non si sta sentendo l'audi
ottimo non si stava sente l'olio del
gioco è ditemelo dovuto mettere adesso
non c'era l'audio del gioco guai
non so che audio emozionante possa
essere questo cesa non ferraglia che si
scontra con un'altra ferraglia un po
l'aido c'è qualcuno che ha fatto sto
gioco in live di youtube e role 3 metri
voglio vedere come come colposa hanno
fatto no perché dai curiosità nel letto
da dico dopo però ripreso nel video che
ho fatto di getting over it a un anno fa
quindi quelle quattro episodi che ho
fatto dove c'è tutto il gioco quando ho
preso il serpente non è che il
salvataggio non lo so ho dovuto rifare
che mi ottimo
dai perché fai schifo il pene o no no no
ok almeno lì davvero gli stai fermo
fermo ok va bene sono contento va bene
così tirati su su su bene ok calmi e mi
ero salvato ma non ce l'ho fatta va bene
bla non so parlare cioccio ha l'ansia
ciò c'è l'ansia
non è vero ma perché il mio vicino mi
vorrà uccidere dai perché è così
difficile fare questa cosa perché prima
non era così difficile adesso lo è
niente niente voglio morire voglio
morire adesso pinchia stoffa c'è una
roba orribile volevo darmi lo slancio
per andare a destra ma non l'ha fatto
lui
meglio così perché manca tanto qui e non
ci arrivo perché niente niente proprio
niente niente niente
niente niente niente chris ban
poi certo microfono delle palle che nel
golf a tutto il mouse
no il gancio non lo potete prendere lega
è finto f
sai quante volte ci ho provato a preferì
che non funziona il gancio e se l'ha
mica scemo so c'è un po sì però noi in
questo caso poi debito poiché guardami
gli faccio vedere il cane in live se
arriviamo a chico di rischi pil quindi
iscrivetevi con tutti i secondi account
faccio vedere se se la mia pazienza non
mi uccide prima
ok bene non è vero
dai ragazzi perché deve essere così
difficile perché mi dovete fare odiare
il demonio che va beh non sarebbe male
no facendo esattamente alla pari ma io
mi domi m'illudo che posso lanciarmi a
destra agganciandomi a sinistra non puoi
farlo perché è difficile prima non era
così difficile
ti vede incassato sbaglio trova passo
così miei pomeriggi dai o no di prendere
per il culo perché è difficilissimo
prima non lo era dai ragazzi che muoiono
ne metti il culo su quella fare il culo
termo dai raga dai non prendiamoci per
etico sul serio regali più ammazzo
qualcuno vi giuro è bello bravo bravo
complimenti complimenti
raga il gancio nella roccia non funziona
è finto se non mi sarei già preso sei
anni fa
voi non avete io se voi non avete
getting over it e non ci avete mai
giocato
io non vi so spiegare quanto è difficile
cioè non solo è proprio difficile
muovere il martello cioè non so
spiegarvi quanto è frustante sta roba
ecco guardate come sono rimasto
vi prego guardate come ti prego
[Musica]
il proceso vabbè portatili ok molto bene
ok fermi no mi chiamano ma le gare
iniziato a parlare il narratore
ringraziando dio
il momento è delicato davide ciao fari
ciao davide
prima ti ringrazio per la gioia che mi
ha trasmesso ultimamente prego grazie a
te poi cosa ne pensi di nome negative ha
fatto i dislike dc numeri negativi non
ha fatti un sacco in realtà ci hanno
fatto un botto diffuso il nome negativi
penso che tentenni dislike l'ho detto
all'inizio della live riguardati
iniziare a live iscrivetevi tutti con un
altro account a mio canale come se non
l'avessi capito dice che ansia molto
bene molto bene
molto bene no
praga cosa gli sta succedendo alla testa
cosa fa non ci sta credendo neanche lui
ci sta credendo di dove sei vero perché
ti guarda in basso
guardalo
cosa fa guardi che ce l'hai piccolo
sono contento di essere caduto qua e non
più sotto di così però volendo sarebbe
stato meglio cadere più sopra ma non fa
niente voglio morire adesso quanto mi
rimane di daigo un'ora o un'ora di
un'ora in un ora devo finire il gioco un
ora manca solo quello un'ora e un quarto
o un ora per finire in gioco io non so
se ce la farò
ci devo provare sito nicchia di cappello
i ragazzi non ho parole dai minchia poi
questa è la parte facile se poi se
riesco a finirlo facciamola reaction
dello speed run così perché mi va di
farlo no stavolta ti incula ecco no no
io che il cielo jump square che non ho
voglia di prendere e non mi hai fatto
paura soldi prima si e ne ho pagato il
prezzo era di armi e mi confermate che
era per halloween sta roba
cioè ancora natale ed ha mantenuto il
coso di halloween vabbè che compare dopo
un po che cali in questo punto tra
l'altro non compare sempre
fai rocket league che ti procura almeno
tentazione al suicidio ha voglia
dai che schifo ma non posso no
ci ho provato
raga che palle è molto minimale
un'oretta dai dai dai
normale che tu dici da sola
eh no no ok
vedo che ci sono volte che non ci arrivo
asta roccia dove sono adesso ci sono
volte in cui la superò come una via di
mezzo no no no no stai fermo fermo io
non sto fermo lega ce la posso fare
dai dai che fastidio dai ragazzi perché
questo no raga io veramente lo giuro non
poi oggi annuncio non ho mangiato non ho
dormito poco io io io vi ammazzo
grazie a non me li merito e di li darò
un giorno che siamo quasi 5000 di tutti
i meritati non è vero però grazie anche
se molti invece la farei a finire in no
non penso cioè allora allora il discorso
non è questo discorso e che sicuramente
tra un'ora qualcosa succede o lo finisco
o caldo sotto e non lo posso più finire
perché sono ritornate all'inizio quindi
o lo finisco non è che trovano ora
rimango qua oro oro fini molto prima di
un'ora finirà questo di questa live o lo
finisco o no quindi non ce la vedremo
cadeau all'inizio o no quindi non lo so
se ce la farò però non è che finisce che
sono ancora nell'incubo linee tranquilli
quindi lo vedrete un finale in un modo o
nell'altro tranquilli io spero più
nell'altro che è quello positivo sarebbe
figo finirlo in live possibile porca
vacca laida morta
grazie fa vj non te li meriti suoi
scritti ma perché non sai andare su per
che cosa devo fare
dati melo no ragazzi io vi giuro vi
ammazzo da voi ma chi ha fatto suo gioco
non ce la posso fare vi giuro su dio via
con un omicidio fa quando fai un po
confermi freni quello che sto dicendo
credo che non arriverà mai a 5 degli
iscritti ma un giorno se dovesse
arrivarci non so se avrei le palle che i
tool di fare un arazzo getting over ma
guardava neanche io so come sto facendo
questa quindi ti ringrazio già col asma
vorrei capire come faccio io ad averle
queste palle grazie mille
se non lo finisci o ci devi fare un
altro laghi dove lo finisce si no
è già un miracolo che l'abbia fatto due
live su getting over it dove questa è
forse la live per voi migliore che abbia
mai fatto per me peggiore e non la farò
mai più mai più lo toccherò stato di
install mi disinstallo il computer di
formato tutto il prossimo che mi dice
che devo usare ghiaccio lo uccido dai
ragazzi facciamo i seri dai dai
il telefono dove te le fa via via via
via con me ne frega niente vi ha visto
la ix20 tipo rilazi nel culo quando non
serve complimenti
no rega se io non do ma perché non
riesco a farlo e ogni tanto si stai
fermo ciao
porco schifo dai sali madonna niente non
so niente non fa io se cado e torno
indietro che non posso più andare avanti
quindi come ho fatto prima
spengo la live noi ve l'ho detto dai
ragazzi perché non esiste perché è
partito un dissing a t series nei miei
commenti molto bene molto bene devi
morire e devi morire e devi morire
voglio ucciderti perfetto piano se
arriviamo a 5.000 di questa voglia far
vedere sun
sì assolutamente sì ma non ci arriverà
non tel vi sfido con il fate al country
scrivete prova proviamo
stato comunque salvi dove lo faccio in
settimana vini tranquilli messo
scusatemi mi sto caricando perché se poi
vado a cado mi ammazzo quindi voglio
nativo sentirmela c'è il suo gioco te la
devi sentire perché se non te la senti
fai una cagata hd giu quindi me la so se
mi sto caricando scusatemi chi gay t
series gay perché è partito il di sting
artisti di temi come il cos'è successo
se arriviamo 5 milioni di iscritti
mischiate con tutti i vestiti secondi
account
faccio un dissing t series anch'io lo
faccio piuttosto non lo so cosa centrati
si vedano è sparita è iniziata st so di
singoli come grazie a matsumoto
no
no no no turco demonio morta subito
non li faccio subito devo di farlo
subito veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce devi tornare lì in 4 secondi
conto alla rovescia subito subito subito
dovrei tornare lì subito mi sono rotto
le palle mi sono rotto le
mi sono rotto le palle nelle sono rotte
basta basta sto gioco lorido latrina
basta che palle voglio arrivare alla
resa dei conti adescato giu
definitivamente o no voglio vedere
quello voi io voglio vedere quello se
cado mi ammazzo
non me ne frega niente perché
ti prego puoi fare veloce per cortesia
voglio arrivare lì per cortesia grazie
grazie gentile porco demonio grazie
voglio arrivare lì molto gente no voglio
arrivare allo ragazzino è solo impegno
come non ho mai fatto prima e voglio
arrivarci non me ne frega niente
piuttosto sto zitto non dico nulla ma
devo arrivare lì piuttosto mi ammazzo ma
ci arrivo perché non ce la posso più
fare ve lo giuro molto bene e fino a qua
ok
questa cosa mi fa incazzare che la gente
lo fa in 20 secondi sto pezzo volevi
sfiderà come fanno hanno una vita hanno
una famiglia hanno una ragazza no la
risposta è no
mi fa ridere che torna sull'incudine no
perché madonna perché quando mi aggancio
gli torna indietro perché devi tornare
indietro stai lì fermo io vi giuro lo
ammazzo e ci voleva tanto
ecco piano
ok no va bene sali perfetto nella parte
difficile l'abbiamo fatta ok non
sbagliare adesso la parte difficile
l'abbiamo fatta ti ammazzo perfetto
l'ultimo l'ultimo l'ultimo migliaccio
un'ansia che non avete c'è un'ansia che
merita non lo potete capire giuro
no no no no no no no sì sì sì sì questo
questo questo questo questo questo
volevo questo allora allora io non ho
più account per riprovarci quindi se io
cado giù
di qui ho perso la live non gioco più se
cado giù di la sinistra volevo dire di
laio indico il mio monitor non lo vedete
se vado giù di là io ho smesso
vogliamo samp dovete iscrivervi con un
altro canale per quel arrivo arrivare a
5 viene inflitto in questo video è loro
se no lo vedremo in settimana
adesso se io vado su col col secchio è
arrivo sopra il gioco lo finisco perché
ce la faccio a fare volevo se io vado
giù di qua non ci va proprio bene
credono no non lo voglio concludere
no no no no ok va bene basta che non
cado giù
prima quanto sono durati tre secondi
ragazzi mi sto pagando addosso non fare
cagate va bene se no perché mi fa cagare
addosso il secchio dondola troppo secchi
o dondola veramente tantissimo che va be
che kakà quello che la gente non sa che
quando è registrata video su getting
over it molto vagamente aic impiegato lo
stesso tempo il noci impiegato di più
adesso perché sono più o meno
destreggiarmi c'avevo piatto molto di
più molto di più
[Musica]
beh mica fatto rischiato se lo fa forse
il di dondolarsi la il modo giusto
forse devo tondo l'army no che anzi è
incredibile
no ragazzi sottoposto salvataggio non
c'ho pignero dai sì sì sì sì giusto
no no no no parco demonio porco
importante che non cado giù nel serpente
ecco bravo era giusto la giusta
no no
molto bene bravissimo bravo bravissimo
bravissimo velocissimo dai dai
sì non ci credo devo superare questa
montagna e l'ho fatto
no rega devo superare la montagna il
problema è che è difficilissimo superare
la montagna no no è difficilissimo no no
no no no sì sì sì no no no no no no no
no no no no
e difficilissimo rega dai dai dai dai
non è vero dai ti prego ti prego dai sì
sì sì 4 ripido dai non ci credo dai dai
dai non ci credo
lui ci credo non è possibile non è vero
lui ci credo non è vero raga rega o
minchia nicchia minchia miglia dai dai
dai dai dai
dai dai dai dai dai dai link che ansia
celo celo celo celo ti frego
grazie barney stinson andiamo a
rimorchiare tutti e due con la madre di
un fratello non fare il porcello
no non cadere minchia rega grazie pente
allora siamo non ci credo siamo a quanto
siamo alla fine alla fine c'è c'è questa
torce il carrello poi c'è questa cosa a
destra le di pietra e poi c'è la torre
ho finito e ho finito se so però la
torre ecco non cadere per cortesia non
cadere giù dai dai dai dai
va bene va bene piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano piano piano ma piano
piano
no dài dài dài minchia legaccio un'ansia
dai vi prego o se finisco vi dovete
scrivere con tre account a testa
me lo merito come minimo già velo merito
adesso quindi uno adesso gli altri due
solo céline è impossibile non ci credo
che c'è una sto male sto male sto male
non sono mai arrivato qua una seconda
volta mi è perché poi ci ho riso kato
mai ci sono arrivato alla seconda volta
i fatti non mi ricordo quasi niente
dai
mi piace devo fare ma secondo me se mi
spingono a vado più su dai dai dai dai
dai
perfetto ci sono
no ci siamo ragazze se se se cado qua
potrei cadere dalla montagna e cadere
tutto giu
minchia iscrivetevi subito al canale me
lo merito li mortacci mia
minchia che bordello fatto e solo se
vinco col secondo account nostro solo
selim però dovete loggare non fate mai
peer la parola la parola si mantiene
minchia non ci credo sono in a sono in
ansia perché vi prego vi prego ogni
volta che dici molto bene primini mentre
sapientino ricordi si ma nel dopo
parliamo dopo parliamo dopo ti prego
grazie motogp va se cado cado giù dalla
montagna e quindi devo rifare il pezzo
se non tutto quindi non devo cadere sono
innanzi sì ma è il pezzo finale
vado no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no va bene va bene va bene va bene va
bene non importa l'importante che non
cado giù
l'importante che non cado giù dal
serpente va bene bravissimo sono
contento se vai su ti prego chi comprerò
ti adotterà un bambino sano ti prego vai
ti prego non cadere giù c'è nessuna vita
ci ho messo una vita ti prego farlo per
le bocce non lo so ragazzi ragazzi
facciamo i seri
vi prego vi prego vi prego ti prego non
mi fare questo ti prego sono stato
sempre bravissimo faccio i video in un
click day tomai
dai dai dai ti prego non cadere non
cadere ti prego ti supplico è difficile
lo so però tutto ciò che lo puoi fare
ti prego prego tempo dai su
va bene no non va bene non va bene così
non va bene vai giù che stai andando la
torta giu ok va bene l'importante è non
cadere dove c'e il secchio che poi un
casino
nell importante non cadere dovesse che
va bene dove lo rifaccio lo rifaccio ti
prego però stai su su mi chiedo ancora
mille vi giuro ma neanche quando
rimorchio va il super l'amor di gesù fa
pure rima ho fatto prima
scusatemi ma ho fatto prima come ho
fatto come ho fatto prima come cos'hai
fa come sto facendo di diverso da prima
vai perché non ti agganci quanti
problemi
devo solo passare questo punto questo
passa lo per favore passa lo passa lo
passa a questo punto questo lo passi lo
passi
minchia che ansia di vivere porco
demonio perché io devo giocare a questa
roba vai su come hai fatto prima
come hai fatto vai su non cadermi capo
in questo punto non ha pause so morendo
sto sudando non è vero mi chiami sono
salvato vice per l'amore di gesù
giuseppe maria vai su vai tutto su ti
prego l'hai fatto che l'ho fatto prima
l'ho fatto prima come niente come fosse
una scala mobile vai su dai che ce la
faccia da che sono arrivato troppo
avanti per poter perdere sono levati
trappola ne devo superare la montagna è
difficilissima come ho fatto prima
perché se vole no no no ti prego non ci
credo mi sono salvato
non è vero mi chiami sono salvato come
ho fatto a non cadere
sto sudando sto sudando con le mani sto
sudando sto sudando sto sudando con
tutto il corpo con qualsiasi parte del
mio corpo si avete capito bene andiamo
avanti
faccio una tisana sa di cosa sta
montagna vi prego
cosa è successo si incriccato cos'è vai
su vice magagna vai su sopra sopra di
sup
madonna ti prego chi presto veramente il
mi metto in mutande sto sudando
tantissimo ok come ho fatto prima
tirarmi così forte perfetto bravo bravo
no bravo no ok
sono quello solo quello di superare quel
punto questo punto su però e noni a
parco super a quel punto supera la super
a quel punto superano non è difficile te
lo giuro l'ho fatto prima
dai dai dai
no no pastore money no no no no no no no
belle
ago
dopo un attimo calmarmi scusatemi ma gli
spicci vola non solo il martello di
scivola il mouse sotto la mia mano
perché la mia mano e un lago di sudore
dai come cane chi
iscrivetevi al canale chi non si scrive
un buffo schifoso mi sto facendo un culo
così me lo merito
cazzo iscrivete vado
calma con caldo caldo caldo se la fretta
non lo mando aggiungiamo di tutti
calmati caglioti no ti de vita al mare
devi stare calmi per infilare quel
piccone dentro la neve sulla scrivania
abbastanza grossa per farsi movimenti
crimp io come ho fatto prima
come ho fatto finta come fatto no che
cosa minchia fi
dai dai
l'ultimo punto l'ultimo punto solo
questo non ti chiedo nient'altro poi
morire dopo puoi morire finisco questa
leva e muori
va bene
porco demonio ma per chi ha una certa
scivoli cosa faccio di sbagliato
rispetto a prima ma perché scivola una
certa cosa e cosa c'è spiegamelo dimmelo
nord in barche non capisco il martello e
nella neve quindi devi tirarti su su
dipiù scivola si sa perché non capisco
come dovrebbe il meccanismo non lo
capisco mi kg suo a caso prima
funzionato perché no no dai
che palle
ber minute perché sono di vento scemo no
no no no no no
[Musica]
non so se ti ricordi ma tempo fa tutti i
sogni ti scrissi che ti sognai a bordo
di una citroen cactus te lo scrivo ora
così non pensi a quanto s'è incazzato
sai dove me lo devi infilare cactus
ragazzi porco demonio porco non so come
non so
eravamo a ma non penso al caduto
marbella shopper sai cosa mi fa
incazzare cosa mi fa incazzare sai cosa
mi fa incazzare
non me li merito temi lido indietro come
si fa lomellino li voglio
malino li voglio non voglio niente
grazie però non sono incazzato come una
bestia rara sono veramente non euforico
purtroppo non mollare i tuoi un corredo
no è un cuore d'oro ma una testa di gbc
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto no vabbè allora facciamo una
roba non posso più non ho più salvataggi
in un posto nei loro prima mi fa
incazzare che ero arrivato a al 99 per
cento finito la torre quell'alta era
l'ultima cosa io mi tiravo su una volta
in più è il gioco era finito finito io
sono caduto come un deficiente
ero a tante ero al 99 per cento del
gioco e avevo vinto ero finito
no avevo finito ora sono finito che è
diverso no non posso non posso non posso
farcela
ormai sono troppo indietro cioè non
riesco a ritornare in quel punto io
avevo un salvataggio che avevo grazie a
questo secondo account
dove come dove dove superavo un punto di
che non riesco a fare
e grazie a quello potevo arrivare alla
fine adesso non ce l'ho più quindi io
quel punto lo dovrei rifare che è quello
del
orange che export co demonio porco e qua
davanti quindi facciamo così ci provo
una volta a vedere se riesco a
sorpassarlo ma è invece una possibilità
su un tipo mille che ci riesca quindi è
impossibile ci prova e ci riesco bene se
non ci riesco porco demonio
ci provo una volta sola perché almeno
c'è una possibilità su mille centri si
sa mai che funzioni ma ragazzi era
arrivato a tanto
ero arrivato alla fine era la fee quella
era la fine avevo finito il gioco
avevo finito il gioco no raga io non man
mano ma non ci posso pensare non ci
posso pensare porco demonio porto non
ero arrivato quello che mi fa più
incazzare è che ero arrivato alla era
finito avevo avevo fatto tutto benissimo
ho fatto delle cose incredibili ma io
mai ci avrei scommesso un euro sulla
esserci solo arrivare così lontano in
questo video avevo finito
avevo finito il gioco devo solo tirarmi
su era finita sono caduto sono caduto
tutto giu porca vacca e non posso
tornare più lì perché è impossibile come
dai non prenda tranche senso ti rendi
conto di quanto fatto schifo ragazzino
non so
io provo una volta una una sola prova
una volta a rifare il punto quello che è
che non riesco mai a fare quello per cui
avevo il secondo salvataggio
se riesco a farlo bene qua se non riesco
a farlo abbia finito elevati se cado qua
sinistra ho finito
se riesco a farlo cosa impossibile ma va
via il dente via il dolore via
no
non importa quanto pensi di non poterci
fare se sei arrivato lì anche se una
volta vuol dire che c'è più fari nuovo
ma è una frase del gioco west lei
semplicemente tradotta
vabbè ragazzo allora io ci voglio
riprovare perché non sono caduto del
tutto però se cado tipo di sotto dove
dovevi fare il salto non lo faccio più
fatemi sapere per noceto
se avete delle domande in conclusione
della live che è finita bene grazie a
dio
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto a me
no a me ha fatto schifo
tutto mi ha fatto veramente schifo fammi
di provare solo il pezzo delle rocce
giuro su dio e l'ultima volta
se non riesco chiudo se riesco avrei
ancora mezz'ora di live e provo a farlo
se no a [ __ ]
ci provo proprio l'ultima volta proprio
l'ultimo azzurro che l'ultima giuro su
quello che volete seccato adesso basta
anche se caso la scala e basta
dai che palle
ma perché non ti tiri dai vice cristo
vice vice i suoi su madonna ok
[Musica]
si vabbè secca basta se cado basta bassa
è finita lo disinstallo completamente ma
mi ha salvato un millimetro ma salvato
sì sì sì sì sì sì sì ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ha fatta e ancora siamo ancora vivi
siamo ancora vivi siamo ancora vivi a
berlino veloce veloce abbiamo mezz'ora
di lei non ce la faremo
ce la faremo per quelli che ci hanno
creduto per quelli che mi seguono per
tutti per la giamaica per qualsiasi ce
la faremo
ce la faremo ce la faremo ce la faremo
ce la faremo ce la faremo lo faccio lo
faccio lo faccio
crediamoci ragazzi dai crediamoci
crediamoci ragazzi crediamoci
crediamoci dai ragazzi vediamoci
crediamoci ce la facciamo
ce la facciamo ce la facciamo da ictus
dai dai
noi ce la facciamo
ce la facciamo lo facciamo ce la
facciamo
ce la facciamo a ce la facciamo
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
mezz'ora mezz'ora ce l'ho ce l'ho ce la
facciamo
ce la facciamo ce la facciamo noi ce la
facciamo ragazzi ce la facciamo me lo
sento celo celo celo celo celo celo io
ce l'ho me la sento cielo ce la facciamo
ce la facciamo me la sento mia sento
cavolo me la sento
me la sento
dai dai dai dai che ce la fa ce la fa ce
la fa ce la fai sei bravo sei bravo sei
bravo porco demonio porco ma thor 29
minuti ce la faccio
ce la faccio ce la facciamo ce la
facciamo la facciamo
dai dai dai dai dai dai
ce la faccio ce la faccio siamo bravi
siamo bravi grazie giacomo grazie cribb
at ce la faccio la facciamo ci frega ci
sono ci sto dentro ci sto dentro celo
celo stavolta ce l'ho che schifo di
salto mio nonna lo faceva meglio
facciamo credere porco demonio 28 minuti
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
dai dai dai dai
daje porco schifo lo stai calmo perché
sono mini sbaglio dai 28 minuti ce la
faccio quei misteri ste parti mi
snervano dai le buone buona
con yo porco tirati su parco schifo
tirati su capperi tirati su
[Musica]
ma cosa c'è di ufficio o
stai il cristo stai lì dai dai dai dai
federer
[Musica]
ormai non ne frega più un cazzo non
finire questo gioco delle palle
devo finirlo e lo finirò lo finirò
quanto è vero iddio col demonio il
microfono microfono che mi blocca il
mouse
vai avanti e avanti perché il nose
arriva in ritardo che cazzo è un gioco
tipo battlefield no come se la gas che
cosa laghi che fai schifo
il mouse mi dà veramente fastidio ve lo
giuro su dio 20 minuti
perché non si non riesci a salire come
un cristo normale perché
spiegami che cazzo ti fa tornare
indietro che fisica
a spiegarlo prefetti giuro non lo
capisco che cosa si fa slittare sei
fermo
[Musica]
dai dai dai dai serio serio serio serio
se dai dai
dai venti minuti o ancora ti prego ha
posto a tranquilli la posta pasta pasta
tranquilli tranquilli trovava a posto
easy calmi zitti tranquilli a posto a
posto
demonio porco morto perché lei a destra
chi cazzo te l'ha chiesto
tranquillo agganciati a sto schifo mi ha
distratto mi ha distratto e mi stavo che
stava accadendo
non mi distraetevi prego ti prego iddio
vi prego vi supplico grazie ma vi prego
no
a
diceva sto assaporando st victoria ve lo
giuro venuti giù attaccati
mi spiegate perchè non riesco a seguire
qua sulla e prima l'ho fatto sempre in
un secondo
cos'è cambiato da prima
sì
allora ragazzi vola e allora allora è il
momento è il momento senza pensare al
momento
qual è la tecnica per salire su questa
cazzo di montagna qual è la tecnica cosa
faccio di sbagliato e che cosa faccio di
giusto probabilmente di gusto minute che
allora perché non me lo spieghi dai dai
dai dai dai dai dai ti prego farò
qualsiasi cosa se cado ho finito ho
finito la torre finale sono al 99 per
cento del gioco è finito
no no è finito è finito è finito devo
film devo fare questa parte è finito
no no no no no no non hai capito perché
ti muovi storto christian calmati perché
sei storto quando ti muovi il mouse si
muove come lo dico io ok muovi lo così
sinistra destra band sto testando i
movimenti perché gli fa come minchia
vuol
dai no no no no no va bene va bene qua
scusate ragazzi devo concentrarmi
telefono veramente concentrato scusate
mi sono veramente concentrato scusatemi
davvero non leggo ma vera porco demonio
porco no no è la torre è facilissima
cosa non mi riesce mi sto tremando fuoco
schifo
ti prego fai quello che ti dico coi
comandi ti scongiuro iddio se vado giù
tu vai giù se vado su tu vai giù non è
che devi fare diversamente da quello che
ti dico fai quello che ti dico perche no
scendo lo devo farlo bene devo
agganciarmi perché se non vado su mai ma
che cosa c'è di difficile in fare questa
parte quindi ciò che hai fatto la
montagna che erano possibile sembra che
il martello sia lì si sia rincoglionito
al martello il martello ragazzi io non
so che cazzo di prender sto martello fa
quello che vuole
la sul martello fa quello che vuole o
sono io che mi sono sicolo gica mente
chiuso o il martello non lo riesco a
muovere la sopra ciò dei problemi di
movimento
ve lo giuro bravo bravo bravo bravo
puoi muovere il martello così anche qui
dieci minuti mancano devo fare in tempo
devo chiudere
porco demonio porco porco demonio porco
porco che minchia fi no no no no vabbè
come minchia sito a questa parte perché
lo vedete che si muove come minchia
vuole non lo so se si vede dal di domani
ve lo giuro
il marte sinistra a destra sinistra
destra a sinistra si muove stranissimo
che cazzo è ma cosa fai te lo giuro
ragazzi non so che cup
non so cosa succede
cosa cazzo fai vai su vai su girati ma
cosa fai ma fatti la spinta famiglia
avviare il gioco che secondo me sismi
nicchiato qualcosa perché veramente
rincoglionito lo vedi come il mouse
sinistra pensa vita uguale devi fare tu
uguale riavvio riavviato perché sono
[Musica]
qual è il problema
spiegami lo faccio lentissimo lentissimo
no no no era l'ultimo salto christian
era l'ultimo salto era l'ultimo salto
dovevi fare solo quello era l'ultimo
salto l'ultimo l'ultimo salto sei caduto
come un deficiente lunik l'ultimo salto
era l'ultimo salto dai minchia ciò
ancora mille ma vi pare che a 23 anni
sicuramente però dyck finiamo sta roba
finiamo sto schifo di di di letame
uscito su steam finiamolo vi prego vi
prego
[Musica]
stai fermo fermo stai per stai fermo
stai fermo fermo stai fermo perché ti
sei spinto a sinistra se ti ho fatto
spingere in atto
spiegami che minchia fai se ti spingo a
sia da zoom tu vai su no mi rifiuto di
fare questa [ __ ] compagna io mi
rifiuto
raga io sono fermo fermo fermo all ansia
ma sono ferme sono fermo
la donna di giugno biava dal mazzo che
ha creato sto già con lomazzo lo ammazzo
io lo ammazzo 8 minuti mancano 8 minuti
alla fine della live
conte per il bio sono di scrivete col
secondo a casa si fisco sul gioco guarda
cosa c'è che sbaglio ma lo dite
mi devo solo attendere io non ci posso
stare qualcuno queste cose sono troppo
sottili ma non si appende mi appendo
faccio adesso sto fermo faccio gira il
martello mi appendo lui no cristo mi per
niente in un disco fatto sì sì no no no